- [Narrator] This is coffee.
This is coffee being poured into
the most iconic cup in
New York City history.
So, how did they sell
over a billion of these?
This is Leslie Buck, a Holocaust survivor.
Immigrating to New York
after World War II,
he got a job working as a sales manager
at the Sherri Cup Company.
The company wanted to break
into the New York diner scene.
Leslie noticed Greeks
ran most of the diners.
So, what did he do?
He decided to create and design a cup
that would appeal to them.
He used the colors of the
Greek flag, blue and white.
Along the top is a Greek key,
one of the most iconic
designs in architecture.
The sides mimic a Grecian vase.
Smack dab in the middle,
Greek-style lettering
that embodied the very
soul and motto of the cup.
We are happy to serve you.
And, guess what, it worked.
Solo bought the Sherri Cup Company.
In 1994 alone, they sold
over 500 million cups.
And, today, the Anthora cup has reached
full-blown icon status.
Nice work, guys.